in order to go over our last story of
the day I want to talk about you know a
realization that I had the last couple
months was that men are smarter and
better at everything now I know this
sounds crazy to you guys you're like
Pearl you're just you're just a woman
hater well
I had this realization when
I thought to myself huh
the only time women seem to make a lot
of money is in media and that's
monetizing Beauty
on some level
we don't have female Elon musks we don't
have female
um
we don't have female Albert Einsteins
like if women are really that smart why
don't we see the results in the world
and I really think they just make up
these tests I swear to God I think they
they make these IQ tests more
catered to women so we think we're
smarter than we are because I really
think the more you you big up the EGO of
women uh the more men women don't want
to be with men that are on their level
and I just think there's some campaign
to make women feel like we're so special
and so important even though most of us
are just average chicks that aren't that
special or aren't that important and
it's so funny because whenever I bring
this up whenever I say to the chicks
guys we're not that special we're not
that smart and we're pretty average like
if you say that to a guy it's so funny
because we've spent a generation telling
men they're idiots like we'll just say
oh he's a guy he's dumb and it's so
funny because the guys just kind of take
it they just say okay but if you tell a
women women if you tell women we're
idiots when we're dumb and we're just
average and men are smarter it's like
this visceral reaction it's like aha ah
my life is so hard so
trans women biological males have been
banned from competing in women's chess
competitions so you know this is again
we see the IQ tests where it says that
men are on one end or the other end of
the IQ distribution and women are all
gathered in the middle and you know I
hear you maybe there's some truth to
that but you know I just don't believe
it sorry and and this is the this is the
thing like we can look at what the the
institutions are telling us and what the
media is telling us or I can look at
what's in front of my eyes
and I'm sorry but as women we just lead
we make decisions emotionally what do
you think guys if we were so smart the
most important decision of our life
which is picking a husband don't you
think we'd be smart about picking one
like seriously like don't you don't you
think we would be smart and think to
ourselves let me pick a good husband
instead of making a baby with a drug
dealer
or a guy that's cheated on every single
girlfriend he's ever had or a guy that's
super famous
oh no oh no that's not what we do and
I'm not trying to be rude but I just
gotta look at what we pick so now this
has transitioned into chess tournament
so again you know there's no
physical uh strength needed in chess
tournaments but women are smarter than
men right and the average women are
smarter than the average men yet
biological males have been banned from
competing in women's chess competitions
if we're so smart why don't we just
dominate why don't we just kill it like
we just kill everything right we're just
so we're so um
smart so the comments say bro why is
there even a woman in a men's
competition in the first place
Opus is because men are more intelligent
that's not even a competition a
three-year-old infant can beat a woman
Grand Master and you know I was actually
thinking about when I was a kid and I I
have a I have a younger brother and we
used to fight when I was younger because
I just didn't want to listen to him
and then the older I got the more I
started to realize I'm like oh dang it
my little brother's smarter than me and
I really think once as women we just
have this realization guys I think it
helps us when we start to realize hey
women in general were never happy then
we can at least adapt and when we're
feeling like maybe I should leave my
marriage my children and everything I've
built because I saw a soap opera the
other day maybe we'll be like you know
what women were never happy so let's try
to be happy or when we think well I'm
smarter than my husband so I should be
in control
maybe we'll step back and think well
maybe he's smarter okay and I'm not even
trying to be rude guys but we just have
monetized Beauty so much and I'll even
use myself as an example I'll admit this
like you're in an advantage as a chick
like you just get more eyeballs like
more more people want to listen to you
when you're a girl a guy has to work 10
times as hard to get in the same
position as we do in media
um and I and I think we get into more
trouble when we start to just think it's
all by yourself and we don't have any
advantage and you know
um it's not easier in life being a chick
I think it's easier when you know that
it is
um so Kappa says now they just need to
do this for all sports so again this is
what we're feeding into the delusion
that men and women are equal and again I
think there's a natural hierarchy in the
world guys God men women children and I
think the more we tell us women that
we're equal and that we're just as good
and just as powerful and and more
deserving than men I think that's when
evil really happens because
unfortunately when women get power as we
saw with the baby killer um a lot of us
when we're not led by the guidance of a
man we just aren't the best people and I
don't know what it is
um
you know
call me crazy but I don't know guys let
me know what you think in the comments
and let me know what do you think is the
appropriate amount to spend on a wedding
and what are your solutions for you know
prescriptions in this crazy you know
crazy world we're in let me know in the
comments like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time